[Music]
spe
hey um on
me stand with your
feet under your hips when
she's your
okay straight down from your
hips your middle
toe is your axis you
use to determine the vector of your foot
whether it's pointed straight or not
okay shift your weight to the
midfoot which is here underneath
on a
soul when you do
that you're going to bend your knees and
your pelvis so that you get a slight can
going forward your chin goes back
though this is too much can't
so you should be
[Music]
grounded put my weight on that middle
foot there you go
okay come
on there you go so I'm Prett pretty hard
right now
he can stay there without the bracing
EG for har
me what he's going to
do is
simply turn to the 45°
angle so turn leave your feet where they
are and just turn
everything and point this foot at me at
the
45 okay
and this should be hard me from
here same
thing okay so sitay
there and we'll come
around you can
see the speed
angle we we use shenai to find har me
okay some
differences from normal
IO which is wrong iido we'll we'll
Orient East West now
okay is people will
be uh put this foot too far by so it's
wider than his
hips
see han han me is The Stance you adopt
at the beginning of of
kona and it has no task no assigned task
to it so you don't want to look for
bracing you don't want to look for
projection you're looking for
neutrality okay and your most neutral
stance is
shenai so this Han me is
shenai without it being offense or
defense so you Hani means half body so
when he takes at 45° angle the width of
his body gets reduced by half so he's
neither offense nor defense if he's at
full width he's at maximum offense if
he's at the most narrow width he's at
maximum defense so there's a neutralness
to the H stance so I don't want to have
a deep
stance because I don't I'm not
bracing you could probably take more
Force externally this
way than he could externally with the H
me I just gave
him but because he's going to reconcile
Force
internally it's
irrelevant all that he gains from that
deeper stance is he's now more stable
and less mobile not neutral
okay
um so when we
do final hko I'm just in that stance
that's just where I'm standing okay so
my weight distribution is
50 at the offering of the hand so he
goes back because I'm trying to be
neutral it's not until I move into the
technique that I start now you have a
task to do move and shift your stance
according to the task so he has uh
spinal penetration and you'll see me go
from neutral or 50/50 weight
distribution onto the back leg right at
contact
okay some other differences we'll go
back to
you is a lot of people when they do H me
wait I got to fix you cuz you don't know
how to do this is they want to be on
that tip road so I would like for you to
put your arch of this foot on that
line the
ARS okay and then point this at a
45 and then they want this heel to be I
know just slow down let me control you
please they want this heel to be on the
arch
line okay and then they just step out to
get some
depth but this is way too
narrow okay it's not natural to
his body so for
example don't uh hold this up for me
please don't move your
feet just turn your feet so your inch
enti and you can see this is too narrow
for his hips okay so no we don't do
that so when he goes and gets his hip
line fix fix the stest again there's his
hip line and then he goes to the 45
don't worry about East West just go to
the 45 turn it to the
45 turn this foot to the
45 his heel line is
not on his arch
line he keeps the hip distance for his
body because that keeps him neutral in
terms of which directions he can go
which of the eight eight here in air
quot because eight repr represents all
directions okay he's more neutral he can
go in more many more directions than if
you start sticking him on a tight rope
certain directions become a little more
difficult so if I'm on that tight rope
the 4:00 angle becomes much harder for
me to fall onto okay or to move onto so
we don't get on that tight rope okay
so this this foot takes that 45 this one
takes the 90 so it's pointed at the
person all right and because he has the
midfoot vector you're going to see he
has to bend his knees he has to bend his
pelvis a little bit and he has to C that
torso a little forward a beginner
mistake is that the eyes all all always
pull the head down so no the chin the
ears have to go back so his whole fa I'm
going to do this there you go you're
kind of there all right so careful of
that that the the eyes are not pulling
and rounding the top of the spine
here
okay and now with if I push he should be
midfoot I should not be able to push him
over okay good good all right stay
there you have to be
careful that this foot is not roll this
is going to feel weird to you like they
rolling it in so the arch is
caving and that the knife edge here gets
light or even comes up but even on some
people where it's light do you see
that's incorrect the arch should not be
taking that
pressure pick them up more your knees
have to stay in
alignment with the hip knee foot rule
okay when your Arch Caves in the knee
comes in it's out of alignment where are
you this knee's in he has to keep the
arch up to keep the hip knee middle toe
alignment
okay so
no keep that alignment okay no
alignment and then
watch that ankle
angle that it's not here because my
knee cannot go past my
toes the max that I can do is knee to
toes
okay so when he's pushing
here I don't have to be like this TR
okay cuz we're not moving and I'm not
projecting my knee is not where my toes
are okay all right let's watch those
things
try so he he's pushing pushing you push
your hard you can push you want okay
he's pushing as hard as and I'm just
hanging out
here I don't need to have this to do
that
okay try
it okay so I had my first progression
where he's pushing he's pushing as hard
as he can and I ground that okay my next
progression is when I feel any
compromisation as soon as I I sense it I
will now do the turn of tyo henco and I
will do it with my quap and because my
hip knee and foot have to stay in
alignment that front foot at the 90 is
going to go back to the
okay and I'm going to do this
um
when I feel like oh I'm going to lose it
okay so I hold here he's driving I feel
that and then I
[Music]
move that's our drill right
here so I'm here in Han me he's driving
I feel I'm going to lose it and I turn
the
W he's driving I'm going to Lo it I turn
clock driving turn the
clock load turn okay
now when I I am turning to maintain in
this drill my positional
Integrity but when I turn I maintain my
uh organizational Integrity so I'm here
and I
turn I don't want to go
here so here my hand is moving
independently of my
quad same thing
here and same thing here the hand went
first my qua turns the
hand so care this is what I'm seeing
Sean is your hand goes then the qua goes
and so when the hand goes you feel like
that pressure that's disturbing you is
slightly off angle do you see and now we
do
this what I want you to do instead is
the qual moves the
hand qual moves the
hand different okay you can
hear um he doesn't hit the ground ground
is hard so there's not as much weight uh
on him uh the inertia is not as hard do
you see somewhere in their energy went
out um and you I don't know if it'll be
on camera but his grip came off too
because the adhesion is going to go away
okay so don't do that don't go I can
stay in place more if I bring the hand
here and then go no here
qu here
qu okay try it go so as I go here which
foot is
grounding so there's nothing on this
foot okay so I don't want to turn and
shift my weight onto
it I'm on the back foot there's nothing
on the on the front foot he's pushing as
hard as he can
nothing's on the front foot and so
that's why the front CL can
turn they ground on the back foot stay
grounded qu
turns don't go here do you see you're
clashing now as you try to go back
forward and that foot is being pinned
because you brought your weight to it
and you're trying to turn it and try to
step on it and then you try to turn it
the friction on the foot is going to
hurt your
knee you're on that foot and this qu
turns you're on that back foot qua
turns okay
boom Drive
in when we're here he comes around
here it's the same I'm in that same
position he's pushing and he's not going
to push me
over I'm not over here and it gets
pushed and I knock me
over even though the energy is going
around me the
radius has C he can't he can't come into
me yes he's going around me but he can't
come in he's going to feel that base the
same
grounding so make sure you're not just
here which you will always be off here
when you go like
that and he pushes me you're going to
see he'll push on that weaken double
pivot so
don't double
pivot don't double
pivot single pivot turn turn Integrity
to the outside back onto the midfoot
okay try it
again okay so usually why people do this
stuff or even this stuff is because
they're using the
external and the same thing goes with
the reason you're double pivoting on the
two feet like this and this weighted
foot is because you can't do it one you
can't do it on one foot cuz you're not
doing the internals okay but in order to
turn you got to let go of one foot you
can't double pivot
okay so I I am on that foot and then
it's easy I just turn
okay so we go on now I'm here okay and
then I enter on the turn so my foot
isn't going to be
straight my foot's not going to be
straight
the qua keeps turning the qua keeps
turning on the back foot qua enter on
the
turn cu the qua turns it doesn't go
here the B turns he keeps going around
me one two
so just like as I'm here eventually I'm
going to be here too same
thing we're going to do it in two steps
one
two two
steps
one
two
two okay
try three I have
one and
two how much Circle you do here is how
much structural Integrity you have to
you feel you're going to lose okay so if
uh like he he's not going to push me
over this arm is not going to be struct
compromised even though he's pushing
there it's not he's not going to do it
do you get it but let's say if I did it
would start to look like that you
see so before it goes here before I lose
the qua elbow line that's where I would
enter and I would enter so that I could
keep it
okay so in other words like I don't need
anything here right I don't really have
to turn I don't have to turn I'm right
there inside
hand I felt like I was going to lose
that a lot I'd add more external I'm
going to lose it a lot I have to go way
over here got
okay if you do you have to
obey the single point pivot Rule and the
foot knee hip rule on this line so we'll
go a little slower light and the load
okay so as I feel like this is going to
get compromised this is going to get
compromised here this foot is going to
turn
and then I can step back
straight
okay don't go like
this don't go like
this this foot turns so that means
weight's going to go onto the right foot
that foot will turn and then I can go
back over
on the left foot and the right foot can
turn I need to turn the right foot more
so my weight goes to the left foot turns
and then I can step in okay let's try
that so as we
go if you pay
attention if I need a great rotation
here I had to shift my weight onto the
right foot so that the left foot would
be free to
rotate only then can I enter and Obey
all the rules of the foot knee F
line and if you pay
attention when I shift my weight to the
front foot the right foot I am going
behind him
okay when I'm here like this and I
double pck it I'm not yet behind him if
this even worked and it
doesn't so you're actually going to do
that one more
time here you're going to shift your
weight onto this foot and
rotate this
foot is ready is weighted and so this
foot can now move
and you're in no
h do it
again
boom
turn
turn me into the turn step
up single Pivot Point
turns single Pivot Point
turns e me single Pivot Point turns T no
hand
here we're going to do it slow like this
okay let's
try
one and you're going to shift your
weight onto this
foot okay and the hip is going to turn
that
foot then this leg just comes straight
back turns
turns this s irrelevant now
okay don't go turn
[Music]
turns don't turn then step back back a
little okay don't turn then step back
and
don't turn with your line of gravity
between your feet
shift
weight don't push with that heel Sean
okay it's one foot
turn you're turning the quaw quaw turns
okay Boom
turn okay try all right so we'll just
look at that last
turn so you don't want to double pivot
there's no double pivot you also
don't finish the
turn at the
end the turn is already finished the
turn already finished and the leg goes
straight
by not turning stop
you just smooth it out
[Music]
different
different the turn is very tight right
here
tight tight and then this leg just goes
straight by okay try it